joining us here is none other than the
NFL insider from Fox and a great human
being
owner of founder of MVP merging vets and
players and also the unbreakable
Performance Center good to see you Jay -
my man you know you talk about these you
know the Bill of orion's and the Cowboys
and that's why I hate doing hot seat
stories because a couple weeks ago
everybody had Jason Garrett fired that
week that's true right then somebody had
John Harbaugh fired three weeks ago
right then earlier in the season people
talking about Bill O'Brien that's why I
heat the hot seat story because half
them don't pan out as you know I was I'd
like to be accurate more than anything
that affects families and teammates and
just you know it's we're such a what
have you the league has run the
reactions in the NFL and it has been for
a long time almost like social media
it's like all we lost this week let's
fire a guy and now here the Cowboys are
in first place yeah they are in first
place and Ron Rivera's now on that hot
seat I know you don't like talking about
he was asked about a point blank after a
fourth straight loss it did concern for
his job and he told the reporter don't
ever don't ask me that right because he
was quote-unquote fired the year he was
a soup bowl writer the year before I did
right right he was fired in 10 minutes
that's why I hate those stories I just
hate him now but then hot seats become
so hot that a team that hasn't fired a
coach in the middle of the season since
1953 actually does it in Mike McCarthy
this past week you spoke to McCarthy
that night yeah spoke him right after
and you know he was he was shocked it
happened when it did and I know that
there's spin now as well you know we
want to get a head start and looking for
coaching cabinets that's garbage
anybody who said everyone you know as
well as I do in this league things have
done back channels anyway all right and
you can't hire a guy until after the
year and you can't hire a guy unless the
room requires every time somebody says
we want to get a head start on coaching
search
that's Carmen's I can tell you from
experience when a team goes in the ear
they know that they're gonna be looking
for somebody
it starts the year before they start
looking at guys they talk to agents
there's no
a guy fired so now we could start doing
our due diligence if you only do your
due diligence after you fire a guy then
you should be fired because that's not
how it's done in this lake and you know
so but when I talked to him he was it
Mike's a classy guy he was you know he
was splitter like I'm just proud to be
part of the Packers family I'm really
honored that I was this is the camera
welfare it's like I'm honestly two guys
totally honored that I was part of this
family and part of this the Packer
legacy and he said you know my first
thing I just my family right now is
having a hard time dealing with it so he
was racing home to go help his kids
handle that and I'll talk to alter his
kids they ranged in age when he was out
here she's older youngest is she about
three right now but there's a couple six
teens it's like okay so if they were
ancient age but they you know he wanted
his first thing I got to make sure my
family's good that's where people you
know again this is part of it and you
know somebody says well it's these guys
make enough money that there's not
enough money to make it okay that you
know anybody deserves that their family
their kids who you know they have to
deal with that so so I'm gonna get to
the point where the Packers had to say
in their minds that we don't even finish
the year it's looking again I don't
agree with it because I think he
deserved better and look when Tom
Coughlin they're sort of guys Tom
Coughlin Andy Reid
Mike McCarthy I think there's a certain
respect you should give them one look we
know attending Mike how would you like
to do it right has the best send-off for
you what's most respectful for you Tom
Coughlin thanks I'd like I'm going to
step away right there's different ways
you can do it Andy Reid how Andy wants
to do it there's a way you could do it
where you all come out it's it's never
comfortable and I don't think and Mike
knew he was getting fired we all knew it
but there's a way to do things the right
way and a wrong way in this way I think
it's the wrong way I also look a lot of
people are pointing it you know is
relationship with Erin the one thing
that people really need to remember here
with McCarthy in the Packers and I'm
sounding like I'm a McCarthy you know
right
I am oh because the dude has no politics
room he is that Pittsburgh you know it's
all takers yes it totally is no no
politics but when Brett Farve left Brett
Favre as we know treated Aaron terribly
right and errors confidence was down
here Mike McCarthy said I'm going with
him
built Aaron up even when Brett came back
said I'm going on Greta vastra Greta Van
Susteren doing all that we were right
we remember the calamity that was I'm
sticking with Aaron I am here I'm
building him up when nobody else in this
country was he stuck by him and I just
think that that how did that go by the
wayside
even even 10 years later yeah I just I
think that does I mean there's some
other things behind the scenes but I
just think look I'm okay with sorry you
know marriage is some marriages end some
relationships end right totally fine
with that I just think there has to be
there should be a certain respect to
that of what both guys do for each other
Jay Glazer here on the Rich Eisen show
by the way since McCarthy has been fired
they were like immediately after Mike
Zimmer text me okay can you give me
McCarthy's phone number and right away
he comes down says I don't agree with
that
Sean Payton hey can I get this guy's
like the number of people are talking in
it again and and general managers
calling around saying I just want to
reach out to Mike and I talked to Mike
Ian yesterday said I'm kind of taken
aback here in such a you're such a
little you know igloo green baby when
you're coaching you don't realize
anything else but he's was really
touched by the outpouring yeah so let me
ask you this if Colin Kaepernick sitting
by the phone and the Redskins find his
phone number and dial it up would he
take their call would he would he want
to play for the Washington Redskins I
haven't talked in what I would think
that if you want to play football you
gonna take anybody's call any but I
think Colin needs a plan when four weeks
to go in a season is not a door know
it's a plan like hey how are you gonna
handle all the other all the other stuff
you know your backup quarterback in your
you're gonna be brought in as a backup
or maybe just start with probably you
somebody's gonna say are you gonna kneel
during the National the thing is that
it's the other it's the whole thing that
comes with it
you still have to be one of 53 guys
right so what's your plan and if Colin
says hey here's the plan how long it's
just gonna be about football for me
we're gonna minimize this and just keep
your then I I think that's his best but
I have no idea how to talk to sure right
right cuz I mean miss team's
in the mix there yeah I just said that's
all there's three teams at six and six
Panthers Eagles Redskins a half game
behind the Vikings and the Eagles and
the Redskins are a game out of first
talk football somewhere
look just football so you know and just
like as a sit down like his own greta
van susteren it's all only football we
all know you know we're but you know I
again I understand TJ Yates and Kellen
Clemens and all those other guys have
not done anything during the national
anthem that Colin Kaepernick has done
and that said nobody's asking Kellen
Clemens and TJ a mountain talk football
right you know so it just again one it
totally Shepherd 9 ohm stratosphere
one's an icon right anyway now he's how
iconic absolutely yes
those guys are not two totally different
things right you know and again you just
wanted I think what do we have a plan
here but yeah I mean if I'm the Redskins
when I call them yeah I don't you think
players in the locker room would well
yeah would respondent yeah but I said
you got to see if he's but yeah I mean I
think he's supposed out there on the
street right now Susan Jay Glazer here
on the Rich Eisen show what do you think
is the story of of 2018 as we enter the
final four weeks oh man it's just been
the offensive scoring the the absolutely
you know the Rams the Saints the Chiefs
just what they're doing is there's too
many things to write it's just fantastic
it's been great it's been it's been so
much fun to watch Patriots Dom's right
it's just it's been fun to watch and
then you know the two big biggest trades
that were made
really made huge changes in Khalil Mack
and Amari Cooper
they made major changes and that usually
doesn't happen ever HAP so it's kind of
changed the landscape of how things are
done in this league and and then the
other beer Le'Veon Bell took our pickup
our time for quite a quite a bit of time
that's him I still can't great he never
showed up yeah there'll be a market for
him obviously market for me yeah no
absolutely and then by the way people
say well I took a year off how's he
gonna be ring rust or you know football
no no no when guys tear their ACL and
camper tour tear and Achilles they come
back to next year they're fine it's the
same thing he eat this kind of get hurt
he'll be fine
the Jay Glazer here on the Rich Eisen
show all right let's get it big
announcement coming up you ready
rooting around up ready Brock man will
do right now huh I'll do it right now
all right what do you got okay Chris I
know this is a large macro question but
what have you been pounding the table
for over there for quite some time and
I'll just to give you you been pounding
table for a lot pounding the table for
the same thing that my wife has been
pounding the table for for quite some
time yes so every February wait February
at the combine you run you're 40 it does
it's a big to do it does a charity now
it's amazing you do a great job however
the only preparation you do physically
for it is you probably like do one of
those bend over you know calisthenics
stretch two minutes before you run
that's the only preparation physically
you do for it I know the last couple
years you worked with Brandon Marshall
and Michael Johnson for a day for a day
or two a day that's not training that's
not getting your body prepared to be the
best you physically well as you knife
I've sub funny I know you have it in you
I want you to train I've always said
that the reason why I don't is because
I'm just like every I just I'm just like
I want to be like everybody else just
getting out there and try my best and
not training for you want to be six
seconds or train for it I've heard you
and I've heard my wife and I've also
heard Dion
year after year when I failed to either
improve or radically improve has nothing
but disappointment dripping in his voice
so I decided this year okay to actually
train for it and I called up Jay Glazer
well I'm here today not for football and
I said Jay I want to visit the
unbreakable Performance Center now
myself into York and your staffs yes
capable hands and heart yes would you
feel sat out and you said come on in
mm-hmm and I'm proud of you for doing it
and I've been there for at least two
weeks now yesterday he walks in there's
a van der Holyfield and Wiz Khalifa we
will have at any point in time you're
gonna walk in and you were like whoo
like he's worked out with Nate Boren
laughs you a player by the way working
out with Nate Boyer is inspirational
he's Captain America it's fry know and
it's just like you know he's on in the
next rep and I'm like on 12 13 14 you
know what made the Green Beret like how
he got in Green Beret one thing he did
when after they were working out so for
the people out there I don't know Nate
boy is my partner and MVP emerging
veteran players former Green Beret
oldest rookie in the history of the NFL
he's trying to been unbreakable call the
Seahawks they signed him dude never
played high school football and played
at Texas yep and Seattle but the way he
helped make green brain when they were
working out and everybody else is just
like done around the track he did one
mile of lunges around everybody else
I mean he's different he's different and
we did legs day last week it was funny
ride text he tech I was thinking do I
text him see how he's doing today I'm
walking like Fred G Sanford you know and
he texted first saying that he was
he was feeling hurt and I'm like okay
yep I'm in the right spot we're in the
right spot in inside I will say this
okay in the two weeks that I've been
there already
okay there are vets all over that gym so
you're about it you know just talking
about it you're being about it man
the fellow you told us a story about
we're showing him right there on the
screen who is good no she's girl right
here his story he's teaching me how to
box right now how about that
Adele right here it was a an Iraqi guy
coach who worked for the Marines for
four years and al-qaeda caught him and
cut off his in front of him his best
friend in his cousins heads and put the
blade to his neck and right when it
happened just looked up to God said here
I come and at that point he said US
Marines and his marine brothers found
him and saved his life and now he is
unbreakable families and our MVP family
which just kind of found my bellator
because he deserves it guy deserves a
good day and now he's so here I am I'm
like cuz you know the boxing is after
the whole workout should warm up the
workout the lifting this everything you
know in my arms it's tough to even lift
in my arms or find those my stance and
looking at him in the face thinking that
I can't make it it's it's a non-starter
yeah it's not like there's it's a
non-starter and again like I said you
you looked at me and you saw like on my
face the first couple of workouts you
know I'm wearing it I'm putting it on my
sleeve about how I might not be what I
tell you stuff what I do like this is
unbreakable and it's all positive here
and we have don't ever show it or show
it
don't ever show it if I'm hurting you
we'll never know
you know why screw you that's why that's
it's you know you can control a lot with
what's between your ears and even though
you know we're working on the physical
physical part over here we're really an
unbreakable we've got to build you from
the inside out we wanted to come out of
your soul you know it's successful
people training with other successful
people people think it's just closed off
to the public it's not you just you know
we we have almost like the Soho House
you know
sign up and make sure you're part of the
family but you know he's sitting there
struggling with something Wiz Khalifa
comes over like come on rich hey I was
here also in this position like I was I
came here 140 pounds and I did this
riches oh my god you know at some point
you're gonna turn around him return the
favor it's just community that's really
its grateful and specialist ISM that we
build and I'm proud of you because it's
a scary thing to do
change is hard man change is a really
hard scary thing but it only takes a
second for you to say I'm gonna make a
change all it is it's a fraction of a
second and then you got to roll with it
and in our doors
cuz it's private you could look bad the
only way you're gonna get better is by
looking bad but we've all done it
together and it's you got a team there
doing it with you together you you know
I don't even honestly don't care about
your 40 time I care about the work that
you're putting in there cuz you put me
too but I care about the 40 time coaches
they're they're great man a great family
brother great really and every day you
know we're trying to build him up more
and more and more and every day he's
like why can't I do this and especially
like you know our our boxing part MMA
part we're doing we do that she's better
than anything Oh bring my hand back Mike
rich yeah you're not a professional
fighter we're good rich let's stop
beating up on ourselves right here we're
not ready for a fight yet that's true
right
but I'll tell you what man it's a great
spot and how do you like me now Chris
I'm really impressed with merging vets
and players seriously I called him up
the first words he goes absolutely let's
get it done done and you know I mean
he's about time you've got an incredible
performance center there man you guys is
great it's great I love coming there do
you uh have you guys noticed the
difference in the sexiness and last few
weeks I mean
he's limping a lot he's really is
whatever and everybody loves having you
in there man you know so it's great to
see it get appraised thanks for coming
here you later today I'll see you later
today sir yeah every day sir I've been
coming almost every damn day for ten
weeks I want you to come let's Jenna
Wednesday night yes we're gonna find a
Wednesday night this December for sure I
want to come at night it's tomorrow
night yes oppa more night okay you guys
oh and by the way mmm just we talked
about this our biggest donor or MVP
mm-hmm was Mike McCarthy a sight unseen
met one of our MVPs who was the SEAL
Team six commander of the captain
Phillips mission just his store and he's
like and there was a vet we have named
AJ grew up in in Green Bay and he was
just volunteering for us and McCarthy
said he only volunteers I said yeah he
says no you got a higher than full time
and wrote a check so we could hire this
guy full-time and then Dan Quinn just
wrote a check to open up MDP Atlanta
where we're starting next Tuesday MVP
Atlanta go on our website vet some
players yeah and if you're an ex-nfl
player pro athlete X combat vet go in
there Tuesday night Randy Couture Nate
Boyer Brian Stann those guys all be
running it down there will be every week
glazed or at Jay Glazer you're the man
glaze
thank you brother I'm sure I'll see you
later today the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience